, David, who could actually defeat Trump in
the twenty, twenty four Republican primary?
You know, I don't know how to answer
this question unconditionally, because
it all depends on whether Republicans still like
and support Trump in twenty twenty four. We we.
Talked with Bill Share earlier this
week, and he
explained something that is intuitive to many of
us, which is until we know what happens in 2022
and we see whether Trump is in or out of favor
with Republican voters and the Republican elected
officials between 20, 22 and 2024. How can we say
what the outcome would be of a 20 24 primary with
Trump as a candidate? If Donald Trump still has
the majority of the Republican electorate behind
him, as he does today, nobody can beat him. Quite
simply, nobody would be able to beat Donald Trump
if come 20 24. The numbers are as they
are today, which is nearly two thirds of
Republican voters say if Trump started his
own party, I would go with him and abandon
the Republican Party. Something like 85 percent
of Republican voters want Donald Trump involved
in politics to some degree. If Donald Trump
successfully plays kingmaker in 2022 because
people donate to his Save America PAC and then
he successfully primaries some so-called rhinos
that he doesn't like, Republicans in name only,
basically Republicans that don't like Trump,
like Mitt Romney. If Trump gets his, you know,
the Cawthorn Bobert, Marjorie Taylor Green types
reelected and
runs in 2024, nobody's going to be able to defeat
Trump in the Republican primary. The general
election is another question. On the other hand,
if the Republican Party abandons Donald Trump.
Anybody could defeat
Donald Trump if the Donald Trump that runs
in twenty twenty four is sort of down and
out,
all of his friends have lost in 20,
22. The Republican Party has moved away from
him. And it's become very clear that Joe Biden's
pandemic response was the right response
and just humiliates the failed response
from Donald Trump in 2020. Then Trump really
has no shot. And a lot of this has to do with
the midterms. We don't know who will be revived
through the midterms. If people like Cawthorn,
Bobert and Green are reelected in the midterms,
then Donald Trump could be sailing on the wings of
them. And even more Trump in candidates to twenty
twenty four. On the other hand, it could go very
differently if the midterms don't go well for
Republicans. Bill, Cher said earlier this week
that he has this hypothesis that
one party has
has to lose the White House three times
in a row before you see real introspection
and change. If he's even partially right, Trump
merely losing in 2020 is not going to be enough.
What we see over the last several weeks is that
while Trump's polling is still strong within
Republicans, his political stature is diminished.
Search interest in Trump is being diminished. His
public statements seem particularly pathetic,
like when he put out that statement saying,
please remember when you get the vaccine that
it's thanks to me, it was increasingly pathetic.
So we'll have to see what happens in 2022. It's
not clear to me that Democrats get killed in
the midterms. Traditionally, the expectation
is when a party takes the White House from
another party in one year in the immediate
midterms, two years later, they get crushed.
Doesn't always happen. But but it often does.
I don't know that it's going to be the way it
goes in 2022. I think it's just early. But I
think there's a lot of reasons that Democrats
could actually do OK if there is not. And a lot
of this has to do with covered in the economy,
barring some like terrible covid variant mutation
that completely outruns the vaccines. We have a
vaccination program right now that's going well
and we are likely to have modified booster's
from Pfizer and Moderna maybe as soon as the fall,
maybe January, which will deal with the newer
variants if we deal with the pandemic. Vaccination
continues going well, and it will be attributed
at least partially to Joe Biden taking over. He
got the stimulus bill done. If the economy does
well and the economy is expected, new Goldman
Sachs and listen, Goldman Sachs love him or hate
him. Their timeline last April about the pandemic
was exactly right. They predicted late November,
early December, health care workers will start
being vaccinated exactly the way it went. They
said here's when the final, you know, the big
peak is going to be. Goldman Sachs just put out a
prediction, an
analysis, a forecast
that twenty, twenty one is going to be very
good economically for the country. If all of
that happens. It's not clear to me that Democrats
go down in November of twenty, twenty two. Now,
it's still a ways away. We're still, you know,
twenty one months or something from that period.
And a lot can happen between now and then. But if
Biden essentially is seen as the guy who reopened
the country, did vaccination and beat the virus,
I think it's tough to say Republicans do super
well in twenty twenty two. And that probably
doesn't bode particularly well for Donald Trump
in twenty twenty four. All speculative, all early.
We'll wait and see.